it's great to be joined today by David
sparks who is a democratic candidate for
State Representative in Ohio's 43rd
House District joining us today from
Dayton Ohio David and I have known each
other for I guess close to a couple of
years at this point he did some work
with our website sometime ago and
continues to be a sort of tech advisor i
would say uh and he is running in Ohio's
43rd house district David first four
people we've been talking about the
importance of down ballot we've been
talking about the importance of building
a progressive base within States talk a
little bit about the dynamics of your
race and sort of what you're up against
right now Wow the dynamics of my race
really came to a four yesterday which
we'll get to but yeah I'm running in the
43rd district of for Ohio State
Representative in the 43rd district is a
just above the the city of Dayton limits
and it goes all the way out into Preble
County Ohio which is right on the
Indiana border southwest Ohio and yeah
this this was a race that a lot of
people expected you know we've got an
incumbent in office with lots and lots
of money but we started campaigning last
December and you know zero degree
weather and have been doing so all the
way through the summer in 95 degree
weather sometimes with heat index is up
there around 105 and as we saw yesterday
they're very worried that a grassroots
campaign that doesn't take big money
doesn't take you know all of the
Associated stuff that our traditional
establishment politics takes they're
scared that though that we're gonna win
and so that's what the you know happen
yesterday but yeah I want to that in a
second I mean it explain I think what's
interesting about this race is tell our
audience the number of votes you expect
it will take to win because I think many
people sometimes don't have a good sense
of the reality that in a lot of these
State House seats you can put together a
grassroots campaign without taking big
money and be competitive
because of the scale of some of these
districts talk to us about the number of
votes you think the winner will require
here yeah I've been told it's not sure
the exact numbers over 28,000 then I'm
sure the exact hundreds number but yes
around 28,000 and you my district as a
you know they have ratings performance
ratings and has a 50 one-point-six
percent Democratic performance rating
which means that I was picked to win
from the beginning but you know not
having all the big money and all that
stuff so that kind of put me behind but
we put together a volunteer force I
worked on the Bernie Sanders campaign
some of the field organizers have come
you know from the Sanders campaign to
work with me after that's all done up
after that all finished and you can get
out and knock on you know when you
figure like 28,000 well a lot of that
28,000 our base Democratic voters now
you're going to get their votes so
actually it goes down as far as like the
number of people you actually need to
convert sure on the same thing you know
would hold true on the Republican side
if you're running things so yeah you're
going towards a middle that's more like
10 to 15,000 and with you know a group
of five people count canvassing out you
know putting signs up out speaking and
advocating and doing social media which
i think the other side just doesn't know
how to handle at all you can reach
thousands of people and we can win these
these races we and right now we've got
19 State House races that are running
unopposed had I not gotten onto the
ballot my race would have been
completely unopposed handed to us on a
silver platter to my opponent so let's
talk about that a little bit because
you're Republican incumbent opponent is
clearly getting worried this smear
attempts have begun I want to talk about
this press conference in a second but
first for our audience I want to play
just about a minute of a video that has
come out attempting to smear you take a
look at this welcome
issues and taught by about winning
journalist artist and musician David
Sparkes what we're gonna talk about this
week ah what's on your mind let's cover
that sex baby let's talk about you and
we should show our warts at all exactly
they don't you there obviously there are
people on the other side right we don't
want to be sick so yes we don't want to
know anybody don't remind a house no
thank you yeah they're doing it we're
going it someone did pull themselves
that's all I got to say come on America
be real real yeah get real you didn't
get here friend going you got here from
bounced around a while check 11 was 14
years old felton titty for the first
time
it was an amazing feel matter of fact
pretty much threw everything out of my
mind it wasn't it yeah so David if this
is what they're using to attempt to
smear you you know they're concerned
right yeah because um actually totally
flipped on him I've had so many people
say like wow I really like you a lot
more after watching that that shows you
a real person with a real sense of humor
and you know all of these videos you
know we did you know online style is a
lot different than the traditional media
you know if I were to you know I could
take any safer from some of the young
turks or you know folks like that who
are really kind of really brash you know
we could we could disqualify from them
then for running for office for their
entire lives or any number of people no
doubt about it uh and then was escalated
also and I want to get to the part where
where we get to this press conference
that you actually showed up at set the
stage for the audience of how you were
being smeared and exactly what you did
yeah so um I showed up with the press
conference about a half hour beforehand
and the first 30 minutes or so we're
different people talking about the my
opponent how great he was and all you
know all that god i oughtta and then
they brought up the Speaker of the Ohio
House to do the hatchet job on me and he
played this video montage that had been
taken from I've probably got 700 videos
600 lost count you know their music
videos that are comedy videos most of
them are community journalism videos
where I've advocated for things like not
closing post offices in minority poor
minority communities or doing
investigative journalism were exposed
mismanagement within privatized
operators in our county jail or I could
go on and on I've done a lot beyond this
this kind of stuff is just kind of a
segment of my my whole creative world
and we had a lot of fun doing them and
people really like you know they've
always said we love you and your wife
what you guys are doing you keep it real
it's fun and essentially it's just art
you know there's all
like what before ever really got
involved in politics yeah I mean it
strikes me sort of like I mean this is
not an exact analogy because again you
are mixing in completely serious citizen
journalism in in what you do but it's
almost in a way like if an actor were to
run for office and then you would
critique that actor as an elected
official or potential elected official
based on characters they played in
fiction pieces and I know that's not all
that you've done but there's some
element of that here isn't there of
course yeah a lot of all the music
pieces that we've done the week that
they featured we're from my band Drexel
and you can listen to us at Drexel
bandcamp com we performed around the
Midwest from Detroit to Memphis all
places for around ten years were written
up in like national music magazines
regional music magazines got a lot of
critical praise yeah and it was you know
it was and it was an act like you know
part of that act was based upon you know
our influences that we got from life but
yeah essentially it was show business or
having fun we work we were making art
yeah so you show up this press
conference in addition they were also
adding the element of of of uh slamming
you smearing you for drug use years and
years ago that you had admitted to so
tell our audience what you do I mean it
strikes me as it's gotta be somewhat
uncomfortable to show up when you're the
subject of smears and say hey Here I am
well actually I was like I kind of
enjoyed chilling up so we got there
showed up and set right in the front row
and they did their thing and then came
the the hatchet man cliff Rosenberg and
he started showing the clips and once he
got to like the one song about me you
know it was like if the song was about
me touching a breast for the first time
when I was 14 years yeah and how like oh
my became the center of my entire world
for a while after that and and my the
whole thing was like this is why we need
proper it was about the Holy took it out
of context they didn't mention the story
included we were talking about sex
education and the lack of contraception
and how different areas where they've
cut sex education
the birth rate has skyrocketed the HIV
and sexually transsexual transmitted
diseases have skyrocketed and so my song
was about how we need to understand as
adults how kids feel at that era of
their life when they're discovering all
their hormones and they're confused and
they're like oh my god girls girls girls
girls or boys boys boys boys and we need
to provide proper sexual education and
you know and reaffirm luck this isn't
weird for you this is like this is a
natural part of growing up and
additionally the they played another
video where we were having a discussion
about the drug war in the the nature of
addiction mm-hmm and I relayed the story
honestly that when I was 20 years old at
a party at the University of Cincinnati
to metalhead guys came up to me and they
were like yeah when he do this man and
we did and I said you know I hated it
there you know there we smoked crack
with these guys like when I was 20 when
I was 20 you know and people have done
you know President Obama has admitted
drug use like all kinds of different
politicians yeah it'd be different you
know if I woke up every morning or did
that but you know I wanted to be honest
and relay this so people you know we
could talk honestly about the subject of
course and so they took something where
I was attempting to add to the
conversation a real experience and
saying you know I didn't like this stuff
at all and it is said it in the video
like I didn't like it never did it again
I did the whole scene creeped me out but
yeah apparently 30 years is not enough
time to go through and mature from an
experience and so it ended up like
totally backfiring in their face like
all the gaps we saw social media on the
news articles we've read were like give
me a break you hypocrites you go back
and smoke cigars and drink martinis all
night and let's just the soak yourself
in liquid drugs all the time if you've
been around political conventions you
you know what I'm talking about yes yeah
drug use mazing and like from you know
morning till night
they you know these establishment
political people drink and in the
hypocrisy involved in all that and so
yeah they're trying to smear me for
being completely honest and forthright
and it ended up people were like I like
you more now Dave and so what happened
was they once he started going into
these things like he tell you he sings a
song about touching fourteen-year-old
girls breasts and I yelled out that song
was about when I was 14 and that's not a
breast for the first time well if
there's any better indication that you
can run against these incumbents
Republicans at the state level all
across the country it's that your
grassroots campaign is now the subject
of these smears if anything this is
evidence that you actually are making an
impact and I wish progressives had a
better understanding of this and of
course you can find out more about David
sparks's campaign at its vote David
Sparkes dot-com is that correct Mavis
was that board dot org I want to speak
clearly this evening vote David Sparkes
dot org in the 43rd House District
joining us from Dayton Ohio David thanks
so much hey thank you very much for
everything Davi you have a great day
appreciate the opportunity come on